first from the i-team a decades-old
murder is solved with the help of dna
a teenager murdered now her killer named
if you have the eight news now app you
were first alerted to the
about this news this afternoon our
i-team's david charns joins us now in
studio and david
i understand they solved this case with
the help of the killer's family yeah in
a way at least with their dna
investigators say dna from one of those
genealogy websites
matched to some found decades ago on
this 14 year old's clothing
back in june 1989 stephanie isaacson who
you see there an el dorado high school
student
was walking to school when somebody
strangled and sexually assaulted her
killing her and leaving her body
wasn't until just a few weeks ago police
identified her killer as darren marchand
police say he had committed a murder in
1986 as well
but was actually released due to
prosecutors just not having enough
evidence in that first murder case
marchon died by suicide in 1995
but a family member's dna matched that
from
the isaacson case you're seeing video
from the search for her back in 1989.
police say none of this could have
happened without an anonymous donor who
gave
money to metro to help solve cases with
minimal dna
get this in this case the team had just
15 cells 15 to work with
we are not here without the work of our
forensic laboratory
you talk about people that work in the
background when we talk about the
success
of the homicide section in this
community we are not successful
without the work that our laboratory
does
in a statement provided by metro
isaacson's mother says it's good to have
some closure but there is no justice for
stephanie at all
that mother going on to say we will
never have complete closure
because nothing will ever bring my
daughter back to us
now isaacson would be 46 years old today
police tell me the attack on her
completely random
i'm david charns 8 news now